[Music]
hello I'm Dustin Kirkland product
manager at Google and I'm joined here by
one of my colleagues Jeremy lui
who's gonna tell us a little bit about
coop flow and his talk at coop con here
this week what can you tell us about
developing applications on coop flow hi
so what we learned at Google is that if
you're building ml systems you have a
complicated distributed system that in
there requires a lot of DevOps
challenges so with coop flow we decided
to take advantage of containers and
kubernetes to try to build a ml platform
that could help solve these challenges
and at coop con what I'll be demoing is
an example an end-to-end example of
solving those challenges using coop flow
building a ml product where the product
in this case is summarizing github
issues so after deploying coop flow we
can access to pidor hub and use Trouper
huh to pa'dar hub to launch a notebook
for our initial experimentation and
analysis here I'm using a custom
notebook image that has all the
libraries we need for this particular
example and so I just click spawn to go
ahead and spawn that particular notebook
once Jupiter starts we can go ahead and
navigate through the menus to find our
particular notebook and this particular
notebook was developed by Hamal Hussein
for this particular example and we can
see that it has all the steps needed to
develop a model so first we download
some data then we pre-process the data
once we're done pre-processing the data
we're going to go ahead and define our
model architecture and we can display
the actual model architecture using the
notebook once we're done developing the
model we can actually train the model
and you can see it's running for a
couple of iterations once we're done
training the model we can generate some
predictions in the notebook and this is
great but we only used a subset of the
data so now we're going to go ahead and
train the model at scale using
distributed training the first to do
that we have to take the code and put it
into a Python file we can then use the
Python file to build the docker image so
this is the Python file with all of the
code which is basically just copied
directly from the notebook image
we can then go to the command line and
we can deploy a custom tensorflow job
which is a custom resource in kubernetes
that we created to make it easy to run
distributed training so we've gone ahead
and deployed that job and now we can
look at the actual spec for that job and
basically it's a bunch of pod template
specs where one pod template spec
describes each replicas and/or
distributed training job while the job
is training we can go ahead and launch
tens aboard and use tens aboard to see
how well our model is training and what
the performance is once we're done
training the model we can take advantage
of Selden to deploy the model until you
Seldon all we have to do is implement
the predict function we can then build a
docker image with our model we can then
deploy using Selden's custom resource so
here we're just launching the Selden
deployment for our particular model
after we've deployed it we can go ahead
and see what the spec is and we can see
that this butt aspect is very similar to
a deployment spec the main difference is
we can specify an inference graph that
consists of the models and once we're
done with the models we can go ahead and
check out our actual web application
just to generate predictions summarizing
github issues so you take as input your
data input is I guess a github project
and you're going to build a summary of
all of the issues in that project
actually we summarized individual issues
so one of the problems if you're
maintaining a github project is a lot of
times people file issues with
uninformative titles in a large part
because maybe they're following a bug
report and they don't know what the
actual problem is so if you're after you
do a little bit of triaging and you find
out what the actual problem is you want
to go back and give the issue a more
informative title to maintain the
hygiene of your project but that
requires a lot of toil and manual labor
so this is something that you might want
to automate by building using ml to see
if you can automatically generate a
title from an issue so as that issue
gets updated as people can provide
comments and feedback on the issue you
can automatically generate a title that
better summarizes that issue will this
help with D do
maybe deduping different issues in in
github and helping developers spend more
time on the issues that matter it could
you could be extended potentially to
solve that problem because one of the
things you you learnt you with with this
particular application you can actually
learn embeddings of github issues and
those can become features for other
models and one of those models could
potentially be to identify duplicate
issues right is this something that
we're going to use actually at at Google
perhaps ourselves right now it's a it's
an exploratory product so it's actually
developed by Hamal Hussain who's a data
scientist at github and so we took that
and we started to try to productionize
it and using a coop phone and what are
the some of the technologies that this
is built on top of I assume at least
kubernetes maybe tensorflow right
anything else
fit into the sort of the framework yeah
so there's a lot of different packages
that we incorporate to build this
product so we start off by deploying
Jupiter hub which is a multi-user
Jupiter notebook solution and we use
that to give our data scientists the
ability to explore explore data and
build their models once there and
usually they're using tensorflow for
that when they're done doing that then
they sort of want to train at scale in
this case you know using distributed
tensorflow
running on kubernetes they then have to
build and deploy a model in this case
they're using Seldon io and then after
they deploy that model they also have to
deploy a simple web application to
actually make those make it more
consumable so how hard is this to set up
for an end user who has a who has a
github repo so this is to set up coop
flow it's just a couple commands and we
provide all the source on in our
examples repo so anybody should be able
to try to set it up and start serving a
model so five minutes - Wow
sure great thanks Jeremy